The joe rogan experience.
I keep getting reminded of,
you know,
that Bill Bradley story that you told,
and kind of repeating the same thing Bill Bradley was,
he was a terrible basketball player at to start big,
gangly,
slow,
not,
not terrible,
but he wasn't good,
but he had the most relentless pursuit of improvement of anybody that I've ever
read.
You can probably pick up the story,
but you know,
Drew's dribbling the ball,
you know,
constantly eight hours,
nine hours a day,
you know,
again over and over and over again.
And that kind of repetition,
you know,
it's,
it's all part of this same pattern of doing the same thing over and over again.
Well,
I'm glad you bring up music is a great story.
It's kind of another like Freddie Roach type thing.
You take the,
he's a,
he's a white guy who happens to be tall,
but he loves basketball.
He's like nine years old.
And I know this myself because I love basketball and I was a kid,
just the sound of the ball swishing through the net.
He just loved that side of the,
the sound of that.
The feel of it.
So he had this sort of visceral love of the game,
but he stunk at it.
He was tall,
awkward,
slow.
There's no way he'd become good at it.
So he decided he was going to train himself from a very early age and I call it
um,
you know,
they have a concept in called deliberate practice where you learned to practice
what you're not good at because we often,
if we're taking up archery or basketball,
we find something that we're good at and we tend to just repeat that.
And then our practice becomes very one sided,
deliberate practices to practice on what you're not good at.
I call it resistance practice,
actually practicing it.
What is painful in enjoying the pain?
And that's Bill Bradley.
He put these special glasses on his head that prevented him from looking down so
he could,
he would dribble on a court for 10 hours or 10 hours,
three or four hours,
and he couldn't look down at his feet,
which trained him to dribble.
That's the worst thing.
You can have fear always looking down.
You're not able to see where what's going on on the court.
So he did.
He did that.
He went on a cruise with his parents across to England and he didn't,
he wanted to build a practice there.
He brought his basketball and below deck there with these incredibly long alleys
that would go from one end of the shift to the other that were very narrow.
He would put on his special glasses and he would dribble back and forth in this
narrow area so that he could dribble with absolute complete control.
He devised all of these other exercises where he could train himself to see
almost behind himself or at least way over to the side on and on and on until he
became so good that by the time he got into college at Princeton and then later
he played for the New York Knicks and the 70s with all the great championship
teams.
People would look at bill and they go,
oh my God,
this guy is a born.
He was born with a basketball in his hand.
He's naturally gifted.
He is so graceful.
He has eyes in the back of his head.
He can make a pass.
Walt Frazier,
without even looking.
They didn't realize that he had gone through the most insanely rigorous,
painful,
deliberate form of practice ever invented by a single human athlete at a very
early age.
Um,
and it made,
it made the game fun for him.
It was sure it was a lot of pain,
but by the time he got good and he was in high school,
all the girls were admiring him.
You know,
he's got invited to go to Princeton.
I mean,
it paid off and he got a huge level of pleasure and the game became incredibly
fun.
But it was all based on these insane moments and periods of,
of pain that he put himself through.